so apple just released their new intel
based 2025k imac
and the number one thing you need to
know before you
order is that you can upgrade the ram by
yourself
and there are two reasons why you should
do it yourself
first off it's incredibly easy as i'll
show you in just a second
and two apple over charges for ram
for 32 gigs of ddr4 ram they charge
600 to make that upgrade and for 64 gigs
they charge a massive a thousand dollars
and finally
for 128 gigs of ram they charge
an absolutely insane 2600
now if you buy the ram yourself from
amazon with prime shipping
you can get 32 gigs for only 120 bucks
instead of 600 from apple or you can get
64 gigs
for 240 dollars instead of a thousand
or you can get an insane 128 gigabytes
of ram
for 500 instead of a crazy
2 600 from apple's website
so there is obviously a ton of money to
be saved on other upgrades
like the 10 core i9 processor and the
5700 xt
graphics card and with that let me show
you just how easy it is
to upgrade the ram yourself with the
power cable unplugged
set your imac face down on a soft
blanket
grab basically any pen and push the
little button
on the inside of the power connector and
then open up the ram door
on both sides of the ram push outward on
the two retention clips
which will give you access to the ram
now simply grab each ram stick
and carefully pull straight up to take
it out on the new ram that you just got
from amazon
there should be a little notch that's
offset over to one side
make sure that notch matches up with the
notch on the ram slot
and carefully push it down with both
hands until you hear a click
and it's fully seated and the best part
is that if you only bought two of these
sticks
you can actually mix and match the
original ram with your new ram
and you shouldn't have any issues at all
once you're finished
simply place the ram door back on and
you should be good to power on your imac
and double check the amount of ram you
have installed by clicking on the apple
logo in the menu bar
clicking on about this mac and then
going over to the memory tab
you should be able to see if there are
any errors or issues with your ram
and if not you should be good to go and
there you have it you just learned how
to save
a bunch of cash upgrading the ram by
yourself
instead of buying it directly from apple
for insane
prices and i do want to mention that if
you have the 21 and a half inch imac
that model does not have a ram door so
you can only upgrade ram
on the 27-inch model and if you're
wanting to buy the 2025k imac
and you're not sure which model or which
upgrades to buy
click that circle above because our
buyer's guide is coming out tomorrow
and if you love apple products make sure
to check out our apple product merch
right below this video thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
one